let's do this let's start the gun
control conversation with an article
though cool so this is from cnn politics
john cornyn top republican negotiator on
gun package booed at texas gop
convention i saw a photo apparently they
were throwing lanyards with his name in
it in the garbage and then they booed
the guy on his pole for the chat i just
want to point this out when we're
talking about politics and the
establishment uniparty you've got
republicans who say okay democrats we'll
compromise and give up give up
give into gun control and democrats to
say the moment you do will call for
twice as much
so the the direction only moves towards
more gun control where's where's the
republican negotiation with democrats on
them abolishing certain gun laws or
repealing certain gun laws never happens
never ever well this is what they
constantly say why won't the republicans
compromise with us okay well by
definition a compromise involves both
sides getting something you're literally
just asking for concessions right and
the republicans give them and there
shouldn't be any concessions when it
comes to our god-given rights and i
think that's a stance that we should be
making saying hey we've given enough to
the government we we've given them all
of our money we've given them all of our
privacy we've given them all of our
trust and they have deceived us every
single day and when you look at history
when populations disarm when populations
give up their weapons when populations
become defenseless it's when governments
are able to do whatever they want with
them and i think it's it's extremely
dangerous where we're headed towards as
a country and i i think there should be
a criticism right now on the republicans
here more than the democrats because
it's the republicans here that are
allowing a lot of this to to move
through oh yeah so this is the problem
with republicans in d.c i i despise
republicans in dc there's all you could
count on your hand how many of them you
could actually rely on to be about what
they're about right john cornyn one of
these guys the problem with the senate
is that it's a retirement home right
they go and raise the age on being able
to buy guns why because they're well
over the age right it doesn't affect
them and so you so the senate
republicans cornyn is already
putting up the signal right now that
he's about to get blown out the same
thing happened to
uh uh uh jacobs uh i think chris jacobs
in new york 23 he came out he was a
house republican in a super conservative
district in new york right at the r plus
23. he comes out and says you know what
i'm willing to
uh compromise and vote for gun control
in about three or four days later he had
to come out and say i'm no longer
seeking the election right
yeah yeah because that's the that's how
much pushback that he got that he
realized like oh i i said the one thing
that just ruined my entire political
career can you recall him can we do a
recall or something for senators um of
well no and you can't do oh i think
it'll go state by state what you'll be
able to do with the senator but i don't
think i don't think you can recall a
senator but in that moment that showed
you that still the the uproar from the
people pushed that guy jacobs out and to
break a little news on this show i'm
actually going to uh be the comms
director for carl palladino in new york
23 to go and bring that seat and and
bring it to a real conservative carl
palladino if he if he's elected he will
be the mtg of the north he will raise
hell in in the in in the capital and we
need a guy like that a lot of gun
control bills that need to be repealed
and and carl will stand up because and
uh that's that district was challenged
on that gun control uh bit right there
that seat opened because of that so paul
knows what the deal is he's gonna go
make sure we're our inalienable rights
are protected it's really easy to look
at gun rights and human rights in
america let's remember that the right to
own a firearm is a human right and if
you think otherwise you can go find a
way to not be a part of talking but uh
that's the diplomatic diplomatic right
they tried getting a three-week waiting
period for all gun purchases look at
there needs to be room for optimism here
and the room for optimism is in our
generation i am 32 years old i am
sunburnt from spending a week in south
dakota which has nothing to do with what
i'm about to say what does have
something to do with the is we live in a
generation where we could very well see
the nfa repealed we can see it
i do not believe in getting doomer
pilled and that's the national firearms
act yeah the national firearms act the
reason why you can't own you have to go
through a special process to own a
barrel that has a length shorter than 16
inches or to own a suppressor which
protects your hearing suppressors make
it safe for everyone yeah the the the
and this kind of comes back down to that
if you think that suppressors are like
hollywood quiet and super dangerous you
don't know what you're talking about
here's the crazy thing too they have
handguns that are suppressed that that
means they've made like hey we're gonna
make this handgun's gonna be safer it's
not good it's gonna be as dangerous and
they're like not that's an nfa item it's
an nfa item so to to to break the stigma
the why do you think he got booed do you
think he got booed because he betrayed
the republican party or because he
betrayed the american people the people
i'm telling you that they booed him
because he betrayed the american people
and turns out when you betray the
american people and you're and you're
running for a republican you lose your
seat you betray the american people
and you're running for democrat you
become president
if you're if you betray the american
people and you're a democrat all you got
to do is come out and wave a flag or or
or make some garbage statement and
they'll say sure whatever as long as
we're aligned socially so that can fit
in yeah you can you can bring economic
ruin upon the people where they're
literally starving in the streets but
you know what at least he didn't make
mean tweets he they're there some people
are masochists you know adam schiff can
lie every single day he can push the
russiagate lies and people just like
they love it they love being pissed on
by this guy they're gonna keep voting
for him but did you know that trump
called him watermelon head
and that's really good
and that's really unpresidential yeah
did he do that yeah i feel bad for
watermelons
well that's the thing that you know adam
schiff and these guys they they sit in
really safe blue it all depends on the
political pressure at the end of the day
these guys are cold and calculated they
don't believe in a damn thing right and
so as long as that seed is sitting there
blue as hell and nobody can touch adam
schiff on a fundraising perspective or a
popularity perspective that guy's gonna
sit there for a while and if it gets out
of his hand it goes to the left it
doesn't go to the right right and so
this is this is the problem we don't do
enough uh i i believe on the the
conservative side
we are not willing to go into those
districts and challenge those people
because
quite frankly it would cost you a lot of
money to do it and you'd probably still
lose right so i get that
but you but we have to build the
infrastructure and it's a long-term
project i'll tell you why i think one of
the factors that that is leading us to
civil war we've had on a bunch of people
on the show we've had on um
billy prempe for instance i love him but
he's run he was running as a republican
in a deep blue district yeah i know i
should i helped him shoot an ad for him
and and and he should have done that
because
what's happened is
you get the gop that says okay we got to
be strategic we have x amount of dollars
that's a d plus seven maybe we shouldn't
invest so much money in that because
we're gonna lose next year it's a d14
well we definitely don't wanna invest in
there because we're gonna lose next year
it's a d28
this keeps happening and happens with
republicans as well it is hyper
polarizing the country you have areas
like adam shift or nancy pelosi's
district or ocasio-cortez's district
where
she's in a d plus 28 yeah and it's
because republicans do not try to spend
to spend money there and get their
messaging out and because of that now
you've got
the amount of swing districts just it's
everything's being pushed further and
further left or right right but you know
what that has done though the
satisfaction with the representative for
each district has gone up since then
right so that is so there there's a
there's a a little that just makes it
worse and it it doesn't turn to the
polarization right because you're firmly
in with your guy right well oh i love
him he's all the way to you know he's to
the right of me i'm uh love him right or
to the left of me
this is also part of the gerrymandering
you know argument right
do we how do what is the way we make the
maps right they have the the communities
of interest standard
my friend gavin wax just won his lawsuit
in new york yeah he was on this show
before but we you know we we uh he
challenged the the assembly maps got him
thrown out special master is gonna have
to redraw them next year i think but how
is it now that it's gonna be drawn out
do you make it so that everybody what is
fair right in that sense and so fair is
when i win
correct that is the right answer
actually when it comes to politics
unfortunate unfortunately as much as you
hate it that is the right answer see the
issue is i mean you have
you haven't
the left is
we should win because we should win
the right is we should win because we
propose these ideas that we think will
work better
many on the left think that's what
they're doing but then you run into
problems of
i mean look the modern left may be
different from where the left was 10
years ago i hear a lot of people like
bill maher and they rag on republicans
and it's like yeah you're talking about
like boomer republicans and stuff the
younger generation of people that align
in this direction are post liberal
libertarian moderate conservative et
cetera there's a wide range of voices on
the left they say things like we should
raise the minimum wage and you see yes
simple question
what will that do
and then what how does it go sheamus oh
yeah so so this is how the left operates
they go i want good thing
i want good thing and then you go okay
so like
how are you going to structure the
legislation to get that how are we going
to pay for you want bad thing you want
that thing he wants bad thing i don't i
don't want that you want bad thing you
want bad thing
he wants bad things and then they put
big big signs saying bad person bad
person bad person that thing perfect
this is the you you ask the question
what are the things pushing us towards
uh civil war or open conflict let's just
call it open conflict the gun debate is
the perfect
example the gun why the gun debate why
the gun abortion is way abortion well
seventeen because pregnancy centers have
been firebomb every four years
right now i mean every four years we
have the same talk in 2012 and 2013 this
is when i was introduced into the the
political gun conversation
uh what happened you had sandy hook yep
and then all of a sudden all of these
conversation all of these oh gun control
gun control gun assault weapons assault
weapons assault weapons you know
magazines magazines magazines and unused
and people made bank
made money off of all of the ridiculous
things that people said they wanted to
propose all these ideas these do
something peoples if that is the extent
of your intellect wow man but
the point that i'm saying is you had all
of these arguments that were made that
all these gun pro gun control arguments
all every single one of them turned out
to be factually wrong ethically wrong or
just i don't know over tyranny so they
all collapsed
and then four years later we had
parkland shooting what happened to those
old arguments that came out of the dust
same exact documents same exact
arguments you could carbon copy them but
i don't think that is a contributing i
believe that's a contribution because
because of the world no because the the
people on the right or the people who
support the private ownership of
firearms respond honestly and say well
these are your ideas but you're wrong so
i'll help you out and correct them and
then the people who propose gun control
go
they don't think oh i was wrong maybe i
should change my opinion it's it's not
politically advantageous if you want to
stop a civil war if you want to prevent
or move against a civil war in this
country stop pushing the ridiculous
ideas that you've been corrected just
talking about the left it be it guns or
any other political issue i posted on
facebook today what is a woman and boy
did every single leftist flip out and i
said i don't understand why you can't
just be like here's my answer instead
they all say you're a bigot it's a
rowing talking point oh matt walsh made
this up i'm not playing games and i'm
just like wow they really have no answer
i don't think it doesn't matter if it's
gun control abortion or any other
left-wing issue if it's progressive
taxes or universal health healthcare
they won't answer the questions nor will
they do any real research and let me
throw it to another example of course we
can talk about abortion when we can get
sophists from the left who are like oh
um you know it's the woman's choice give
me your answer your morality they won't
do it let's talk about the green new
deal
here's the green new deal as it's
pitched we need to invest in
infrastructure that will make us energy
independent getting off of fossil fuels
so that we're not reliant on saudi
arabia or russia or canada and we can do
that with wind with with tidal energy
with geothermal nuclear w well the great
new deal doesn't say that and then and
then we say okay okay i love the sound
of that that sounds really great
actually i love the idea of energy
independence we don't want to be
dependent on saudi arabia what's your
proposal and they bring to a resolution
that says
free college for marginalized people
free health care for marginalized people
and when i asked as progressive on the
show why what does that have to do with
wind turbines he says well it's because
they're the people who are first
affected by affected by climate change
what are you talking about there are
more poor white people in the united
states than than minority poor people so
if you're talking about poverty
what tell me how you're going to build
wind turbines i'll have a conversation
but even when it comes to things that
are considered left that i like they
immediately just changed the argument to
something totally nonsensical and then
here i am as as aoc's getting she wins
her primary talks about the green new
deal i made a video i'm like i love the
idea
let's start rebuilding our
infrastructure our bridges our streets
let's focus on how to alleviate
ourselves from this dependence on
foreign oil we can do that with green
energy in this country and then she's
like i'm proposing the green new deal
resolution and it's like free college
for marginalized people and i'm like
what
that's not nothing to do with what we
talked about but you know what the
problem is people on the left
overwhelmingly just said whatever you
say aoc you want to make college use so
useless make it free
well here's the thing i got bad news for
you yeah it's really expensive and it's
useless the gi bill paid for mine well
well the other thing is is that when
when they couch all their arguments and
platitudes and then without ha they
don't have to get into the specifics
then it leaves that open right they
don't get back it's like well you know
um uh what is a woman uh you know a
woman is you know by definition somebody
who feels like a woman blah blah blah
and then it's like well what if somebody
feels like a cat you know are they a cat
right and then it's like well
what are you trying to say that you know
a woman is a cat or a trans person is an
animal right they they go into all their
little
games right because they don't want to
have to
they don't corner themselves their
response to matt walsh and what is a
woman is
a woman is a person identifies as a
woman okay here's a cat a person
identifies as a cat
no a cat is something very specific and
quantifiable i mean woman and man are as
well
but they're just making weird semantic
arguments now i'll say this the reason
why matt walsh's question was so
effective is that it's an a political
question the average person who's not
involved in politics would not
understand the deeper political meaning
behind it they simply see someone say
what is it and they go
oh yeah let me give you my answer but
when you look at the political debate
and you see someone go um
well actually uh you know the thing is
you go what yeah that's weird when you
ask somebody a basic question and they
talk down to you yeah or they look or
the i don't i think the
he did a stoic job holding his face so
yeah this is this is the issue i see you
know we talk about this comic ian
mentioned it several times where there's
two people and there's a six
from one perspective and a nine from
another perspective and both people are
looking at from other directions
pointing at it saying six or nine they
can't tell they're looking at the same
thing from the other side
and sure
but what i see here especially with what
we do is i'm staring at that and i go
you know that could be a six or a nine
and they go you're a bigot it's clearly
a six and i'm like i understand why you
think that i'm saying have you tried
looking no no it clearly is and okay but
also whoever put it there in the first
place like didn't intend for it to be a
six or nine so the kind of the comic
book view from above fallacy the comic
it's it's the same thing with the the um
blind men touching the elephant one man
touches the ears and he's like oh it's a
leaf and another guy touches the foot
and says it's a tree and another one
touches the tail and says it's a snake
it turns out all the blind men are wrong
it's an elephant
so like the metaphor sounds nice oh
you're so enlightened because all these
blind man can't tell that they're
touching an elephant but there's an
elephant because you said it was in the
beginning what happened when they went
under the hood
no
it's a
that's not a go there
it's the next sequel for jurassic park
yeah yeah we don't know this is also so
when it comes to uh
matt walsh's film part of the the
brilliance of it is that look i was
following this on twitter and i i follow
matt so i saw people tagging him saying
i can't believe matt was willing to keep
this interview in his film even though
he got completely scorched in it it's
like what are you talking about oh yeah
because they literally they think
saying more buzzwords
means you won the argument because you
sound smart they didn't even sound smart
you could tell they were saying nothing
have you read their blog
i i've seen some of the responses and
they're really pathetic but i want to
make a point
you were talking about
defining what a cat is and they can do
that i think what's even more fun to ask
them is why can't you identify as being
part of a different racial or ethnic
group because that actually does exist
on a spectrum sex doesn't but racial
identity does like someone can be you
like a a man and a woman don't have like
a half man half a woman oh i've tried
that before talking to these people how
do they respond like i'm actually i'm
actually japanese i identify as japanese
i'm five percent japanese true story uh
20 korean 5 japanese i don't know i'm
more do your ancestry i'm more native
american than elizabeth my parents
all right but like who is it yeah so but
when i say they don't know you're white
my gran remember remember we had that
one uh that was that one feller in here
who said no matter what i thought i was
i was white yeah oh yeah and i was like
i don't remember that we had a guy in
here and i was explaining like you know
i've experienced racism and he was like
no you haven't you're white and i'm like
well i'm actually you know part of these
other things did you so you don't get to
even if you are did you say that how
many buzzwords you use makes how smart
you are balancing the ticket bellwether
state blue state coastal elites coffers
dark horse dark money earmark inside the
beltway am i doing good yeah no you're
red state war chess wedge issue
look at these these blog posts on
intersectional feminism and critical
race theories from the early 2010s
and it'll be a simple question like what
is racism and then you ask someone on
the right and they'll say uh positive or
negative prejudice based on someone's
race
it's like oh okay so like i understand
that you could you could be racist in a
way where you're actually complimenting
someone but it's a stereotype oh i get
it you ask one of these academics and
they'll say the the word racism is
rooted in white anglo-colonial culture
the british colonizers are traveling
around the world and it's like okay what
i just asked you for definition and then
like i don't know i don't want a video
it's the left internalized
yeah exactly it's this big long-winded
thing have you seen the meme on what is
a woman where someone said that a woman
texted her boyfriend what is a woman
yeah he said yeah this like 3 000 word
treatise on like his thoughts and
philosophy and she said oh you are
is that what she did no but she showed
up
no but it was like welcome instead of
instead of saying something simple and
i'll tell you this there is a simple
leftist answer to the question they
never give it because i don't think they
actually read their own literature i did
so i know what the actual higher level
academic left answer is i'll say in a
second
they say this guy says something like
he's like why are you asking such a
question and how would we quantify what
one was even if we wanted to first let's
think about what you mean by that are
you talking about outward appearance as
in what clothing does she wear or
perhaps the makeup or the hairstyle well
if you're doing that then you're then
you're then you're confusing men with
long hair with women well that certainly
couldn't work whatever talking about
organs certainly and then they just go
in this is long-winded are we going to
say as if anyone ever said like this is
how we define men versus women long hair
versus short hair are you talking to
four-year-olds
so when matt walsh talked to this
college professor and he said what is a
woman and this and he said it's someone
who identifies as a woman that's a guy
who never actually read the actual
literature when he went on dr phil and
was talking to those non-binary people
and he asked them and they said a woman
is a person identifies as a woman
because they never actually read the
literature do you know what actual
leftist academics say there's only a few
of them who've actually written or read
about it they say a woman is a person
who identifies as an adult human female
so um okay
so there's still there's still logical
inconsistencies in that statement but
it's but it's when so when they say a
person
a woman is a person identifies as a a
woman and matt wall says what is that
well an adult human female but because
we're being inclusive some people
identify as an adult human female such
as a trans woman so we would say that is
in the category of women you can argue
the logic there and say okay i get what
you're trying to say now but here's why
i think that doesn't work fine they
never do it because they don't read
their own books right like you the
college professor who couldn't just say
that
i'm talking to these leftists and i'm
like why don't you just give them your
own answer and say next question please
we'll be then advance the conversation
maybe it's because they're afraid of
giving an answer knowing they're going
to be canceled in about 76 minutes when
it changes exactly as big as possible
right be as vague as possible because
let your yes mean something else and
your no means something else oh yes
no because you would agree with me on
that one was it overlapping college that
the guy got cancelled who was like a
left the professor right there the first
people they go after are their own oh
yeah yep you know they're looking
they're hoping that that a right winger
actually says this stuff to go and
cancel they are trained to speak the way
a high schooler writes an english essay
when he's trying to reach the word quota
and they think the more the significance
of the passage of time which is why they
elected kamala harris
yes oh my gosh
come on man wait
yeah i have an ai word expander thing i
should i should take i should take the
definition adult human female put it in
the ai and say make this phrase three
thousand words
and then print it out and be like here's
my answer
actually maybe i can do that right now
let's see if i can do this i used to do
the size 14 font and the size 16 periods
and columns
as an academic i wrote too many pages
again the significance of the passage of
time we were talking about this before
right uh where vp harris and buddha
judge would be the the ideal the dream
tickets to only weird people in like dc
marketing firms right they'll you know
because you have one kamala harris you
know significant passage of time just
filling in words in the essay right and
then you have pete buddha judge who's
the tenth guy on the mackenzie
conference call who's you know kind of
chimes in to just let people know that
like hey i'm here make sure you send me
my my check for the hour right thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you